hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a mid a DA Center
establishing a Masid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
Allah will give you even
more
how are you guys doing it's been a long
time I got sent a video and I think I
know what's going to be in that video
but before I begin I think I should make
a disclaimer that we're not endorsing
any kind of illegal
activities um assault or gbh or abh or
anything like that um that's just uh the
legal uh things out the way let's watch
the video together I heard it's quite
funny um and then we can both react
[Laughter]
together
[Music]
spee
foree
so this is a video of um one of the
Quran burners Arab guy uh who's actually
in the streets in Sweden and this guy
for some reason or another he's got his
gloves
on he's got
his he's got his gloves on and is
jabbing him and humiliating him but my
question is why don't you fight back
it's a one-on-one the guys even got uh
by looks of it 16 o gloves on um why
don't you fight back I mean this is
humiliation if you're going to come out
and say something quite audacious I mean
this is how I would like to see if you
want to be rough and ready and come out
into the streets and say something
audacious at least have the fortitude to
fight back it's one-on-one it's a fair
fight the guy looked like he's he's
actually less weight than you are but
this shows you that you're a
temperamentally cowardly individual it
shows you that your bark is is louder
than your bite in every way uh because
you you're not challenging Muslim people
intellectually and you can't even defend
yourself against them physically uh this
is actually very extremely embarrassing
and humiliating and this is uh the kind
of humiliation that someone in your
position uh is going to always uh do to
themselves having said this I will say
one thing to the Muslim Community that
people like this guy who come
up sometimes actually they give us the
incentive we need to to have that Isa to
have that might to have that dignity to
have that you see love for the religion
of Islam and to be angry on behalf of
the religion of Islam and sometimes
that's a very good thing and in fact
these guys all around in the
Scandinavian region and I don't know why
they're doing it in Scandinavia of all
places but in the Scandinavian region
they've helped us raise a lot of money
for the biggest Scandinavian Masjid and
da Center in the region which you guys
will know uh is the Islam net dawa
Center mid and dawa Center when I went
in Ramadan or before Ramadan I showed
you guys exactly the tangible uh
expansion that's happening in that
particular Masjid and in that particular
place and what they've done with the the
place is absolutely amazing and these
guys they motivate us in a sense the
Muslim Community to take action and that
is the kind of action which will
actually have meaning ful impact for our
future generations and here the
opportunity lies with us again I will
leave in the description box and in the
comment section A comment and a link for
you to go ahead and click and Link uh
will take you 10 seconds 15 seconds to
donate to this mid and da Center and
this guy our mascot who's humiliated
himself for our viewing pleasure
couldn't defend himself physically or
intellectually and he is no match in any
way has helped us do
so the prophet Muhammad s. wasallam told
us whoever builds a mosque for Allah
Allah will build for him a similar house
in Jenna and we know the great reward
that will not only be gained but rather
will fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masid yes that will be something that
you'll have on your
scale